there's this idea floating around that
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
that surviving a disease leaves you
better off and it seems to make sense
because we've all experienced this when
you go through hardship often you come
out more resilient more ready to face a
difficult situation in the future but it
turns out that sometimes what doesn't
kill you makes you weaker
so what happens when you get sick
foreign
[Music]
the Machinery of War
think of yourself as a large country
with a sizable Army to defend it
you're surrounded by enemies that want
to take your land your energy your
resources
this is a matter of life and death so
your body evolved to be sensitive to
damage and to the presence of enemies
because this means that an invasion
might happen at any moment and that it
has to act fast
let's start an invasion and see what
happens the moment your cells notice
that something is off they release an
onslaught of signal proteins called
cytokines
they're like arid Sirens that activate
all sorts of immune cells that then
themselves release many more cytokines
amplifying the alarm
soon you're flooded with signals that
trigger precautions and countermeasures
mobilization is underway
your brain activates sickness behavior
and reorganizes your body's priorities
to defense the first thing you notice is
that your energy level drops and you get
sleepy you feel apathetic often anxious
or down and you lose your appetite your
sensitivity to pain is heightened and
you seek out rest all of this serves to
save your energy and re-route it into
your immune response you become a
country under attack switching into a
war economy because properly activating
your immune system is intensely
disruptive and draining just like war is
expensive for a country as industry
switches to building tanks your immune
system demands huge amounts of energy
amino acids and micro elements to build
its weapons
take fever it speeds up your metabolism
and makes your cells work harder and
faster while creating heat that's pretty
stressful for many Invaders but it uses
up a lot of calories to maintain
then your immune system begins to clone
millions of specialized immune cells to
respond specifically to the enemy
infecting you B cells produce millions
of antibodies every second each
requiring hundreds of amino acids to
construct billions or even trillions of
proteins need to be made to refresh the
complement system a Minefield inside
your blood
cytokines the mobilization and
information signals also need constant
refreshing
usually you acquire your resources by
eating but when you're sick your body
slows down your digestion because it
needs a lot of energy you can't spare so
it reaches for the easiest source of
amino acids and starts breaking down
your muscles all that muscle that you
work so hard for is sacrificed to keep
you alive
if you're young and healthy and fit
you'll make up for that quickly once
you're better but if you're old or very
young weak or suffer from chronic
illness this may be way too draining
your body is literally consuming itself
to keep the defense going
if your whole system is already strained
when you get sick just keeping your
immune responses going can overwhelm
your capacities
your immune system is a jerk our enemies
too
your immune system is as dangerous to
you as it is to enemies there's a very
fragile balance between the damage
caused by an infection and the
collateral damage caused by immune cells
one of your First Responders aren't
neutrophils imagine crazy aggressive
chimps with machine guns effer
neutrophil encounters enemies it showers
them with chemicals that cut them open
but can also damage civilian cells
especially if the patient is already
compromised for example by smoking on
top of that the microorganisms that
invade you often reduce chemicals and
toxins that can cause significant damage
and cell death so a serious infection
often causes many tiny wounds literally
holes in your organs as you can imagine
it's not great to have holes and wounds
in your organs and your body rushes to
close them your neutrophils and
macrophages help by releasing chemicals
that signal the body to start repairs
and most of the damage is quickly filled
up with regrowing cells but others are
filled with collagen a sort of fixal
organic cement that gives your gooey
tissue structural Integrity you've seen
the result in your skin as scars
scar is different from the original
tissue it has no functioning cells in it
it's like a sloppily applied cement
patch it can't do what the original
tissue was doing a scar on your heart
makes it beat a tiny bit weaker a scar
on the lungs no longer captures oxygen a
scar on your liver makes it a worse
filter
and so as you go through life and
survive serious disease after serious
disease the functionality of your organs
May decrease the damage is usually small
enough not to affect your quality of
life but can be permanent
okay this sounds depressing but there is
actually something you can do to avoid a
lot of this damage and train your immune
system
the best way to train your immune system
your immune system is unique everyone
has a slightly different immune system
that's stronger against some enemies and
weaker against others which makes
evolutionary sense as this protects our
species from being wiped out by a single
infection collectively the immune system
of the human species is a spectrum most
people respond well enough to an
infection a few are super responders and
a few don't respond well and die some
people survive the Black Death are more
resistant to HIV or coronavirus or even
resistant against Ebola others are
killed easily by the flu or are highly
vulnerable to certain bacterial
infections where you are on this
spectrum is impossible to predict and
you also respond differently to every
possible infection
this is why seemingly very healthy young
people died from covid while for some
elderly people it was more like a mild
flu
the idea that you can weather all sorts
of diseases if you never get a cold is
wrong you never know what your immune
system is good at until it's tested
getting sick is a gamble in life's
casino with your health on the line
always but there is something you can do
hacking one of the best features of your
immune system when you survive a disease
usually you have better defenses against
it afterwards you gain memory cells that
are very good at killing the specific
enemy you fought that day so you either
don't get the disease again or the next
infection is much Mader and you can use
an incredible achievement of human
Ingenuity that Taps into this mechanism
to prevent damage from disease and train
your immune system vaccines
vaccines basically pretend to be a
disease and train your defenses to be
ready if it ever shows up for real the
goal is to create the same memory cells
that you would get after surviving an
infection but if you can feel some side
effects why should you still do it
nature versus vaccine Dojo you have two
options to train your immune system
vaccine dojo and nature dojo in vaccine
Dojo you train with paper weapons and
learn to defend yourself sure you might
get a black eye or a bruise sometimes
after a vaccine you get sick for a few
days but that's generally it no scars no
permanent damage we discussed vaccine
side effects in detail in another video
if you want to learn more on the other
hand getting a disease to become immune
means going to a nature dojo in nature
Dojo you train with real weapons sharp
knives and swords things might still
work out but with way more cuts and
wounds but from time to time someone
will die be as a kid from measles or an
adult from influenza nature Dojo is just
way more risky on top of that the
immunity you get from a vaccine is often
better than the natural resistance
because they're engineered to engage
your immune system in a more productive
way
of course vaccines are not magic and
sometimes they don't protect us as well
as we'd like them to maybe because an
enemy mutates too quickly like the
Omicron coronavirus or because your
specific immune system does not respond
well to the vaccine and builds less of a
defense
still being vaccinated is one of the
best tools to train your natural
defenses
in the end if we look at the stunning
progress Humanity has made in the last
century eventually we may overcome
disease for good but until then we can
do our best to take care of ourselves
and others your body and your older self
will be grateful to you
diseases are not the only problem
Humanity can address if we work together
we believe the same is true for climate
change one of the main challenges of Our
Generation we're very passionate about
this topic and we've covered it
extensively in previous videos the
humanity needs to tackle this problem on
different levels of society from
governments and economies down to the
individual and there's one way you can
take action Now by working with our
friends from Ren who help you offset
your carbon emissions by visiting
rendocone answering a few questions you
can find out what your personal carbon
footprint is
your first step should be reducing your
footprint but there are limits to that
Ren lets you offset the rest of your
carbon footprint with a monthly
subscription that supports projects that
plant trees protect rainforests and
remove carbon dioxide from the sky we
think it's one of many puzzle pieces
that can make a real difference in the
climate crisis once you sign up to make
a monthly contribution you'll get
pictures and updates from the project
you support so you can directly see the
impact you're making we appreciate
wren's focus on transparency and impact
so you can always retrace how your money
is spent one project we find especially
interesting is refrigerant destruction
old refrigerators use harmful gases as a
coolant these gases once released into
the atmosphere cause global warming
thousands of times faster than CO2 Ren's
project permanently destroys containers
filled with these gases proving with
high certainty that they'll never leak
and contribute to global warming sign up
through ren.co kotskazard to start
helping the planet
as climate change is close to our hearts
we will personally pay for the first
month of subscription for the first 200
people to sign up continue your
cutzart's journey into the fascinating
world of the immune system and check out
these products in our shop learn more
about immune cells and Marvel at battles
that are fought in your body every day
all of our products are designed with
love and produced with Care by us here
at cortexart
right
[Music]